first of all i don't like the term
failure i like the term falling
i think you need we we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer
right if you have stage four lung cancer
or stage four liver cancer and you have
a mild melanoma
with a 99.9 chance of you'll be fine
both of those things are called cancer
and the problem is they're not the same
thing
and failure is the same is the same
which is failure could be absolutely
catastrophic or it could be
a minor hiccup but the problem is we
call it failure so i think we need to
use different terms
right failure i believe is something we
want to avoid but falling
is something that happens naturally and
we want to fall and get get up more
often that's what i think is false fall
fast and get yourself back up
as opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so i i want to embrace
falling
because that's that's taking risks
that's trying you only fall when you
push the boundaries
right but the the the the language
matters because it changes our mindset
especially because it's too broad a
definition for failure
so one of the ways we embrace falling
is by when somebody does fall we don't
say
what have you done we go okay try again
as leaders right um or
um how can i help you fix it and we just
a little more relaxed about it and
and we don't swoop in and do it for them
right
but rather we go so in other words we're
encouraging risk-taking
we're encouraging people to try
recognizing that they won't lose their
jobs
that that especially if you're more
junior you really couldn't do anything
that brings down the firm anyway
and we have to give people the
opportunity to fall and let them either
learn to fix their own problems or
guide them so that so that they can
every single one of us
has screwed up a bazillion times and the
only reason we are where we are today
is because somebody said all right all
right you're an idiot but try again
you know like that's where i know who
did it for me peter and dimaggio my old
boss
years and years and years ago the guy
would never answer any of my questions
peter what should i do what do you think
we should do i'm like
if i knew i wouldn't be asking well what
do you think i think we should do this
then do that
the guy never answered a question and if
i screw up he goes
what are you going to do you know
but i never felt fear that i would get
fired
ever i never felt afraid that my job was
on the line when i screwed up
we have to do that for people